bonjour elena volochine un plaisir vous
accueillir sur ce plateau vous êtes
notre correspondante en russie depuis
dix ans vous avez notamment couvert
l'annexion de la crimée ce conflit aussi
d'en bas ce qui a débuté il ya sept ans
on avait les mots de vladimir poutine on
a maintenant ceux de sergueï lavrov et
ne sont pas très différent peut-être
plus en détail sergueï lavrov
aujourd'hui oui bah sergueï lavrov il
est complètement dans la rhétorique de
vladimir poutine habituel c'est-à-dire
d'abord de dire que la russie est là le
bon rôle que il s'agit de repousser les
nazis qu'ils attaqueraient les
populations civiles du donbass et c'est
de dire que la russie est prête au
dialogue de dire que la russie veut la
paix veut un cessez le feu est presque
en train de mener une mission
humanitaire en bombardant en bombardant
toute l'ukraine que dire la question
vraiment est de savoir aujourd'hui c'est
que veulent obtenir les russes et
jusqu'où sont ils prêts à aller pour
l'obtenir pour le moment sergueï lavrov
en a reparlé aussi c'est les lignes
desquels vladimir poutine ne bouge
absolument pas c'est ce sont ces
exigences vis-à-vis de l'otan à savoir
une démilitarisation des troupes de
l'otan de ses treize pays qui l'ont
rejoint depuis 1997 une démilitarisation
de l'ukraine statut neutre pour
l'ukraine c'est à dire que l'ukraine
s'engagent formellement à ne jamais
rentrer dans l'ue à ne jamais vouloir
rejoindre l'otan est également un
retrait de tous les missiles qui sont
sur le territoire européen et qui
menacerait selon selon moscou la russie
donc ça ce sont des exigences sur
lesquels ils les fermes depuis le départ
on ne s'attendait pas à ce qu'il entre
dans une offensive de d'une telle
ampleur pour pour obtenir ce qu'il veut
surtout que les statuts de l'otan
finalement ne permettent pas à l'otan
daksi d'accéder à ses exigences donc ou
sergueï lavrov
entre guillemets là il ne fait que c'est
une conférence de presse à destination
des médias étrangers parce qu'il faut
que la russie comme unique il faut que
la russie parle aussi à l'étranger mais
en réalité bon là on est purement dans
cette rhétorique qui est la même depuis
le début mais il a fait le job pour
moscow finalement witz complètement on
en met sergueï lavrov ça fait partie de
ces de ses soldats de vladimir poutine
dans son dispositif qui participent à
cette à cette mise en scène de donner
l'illusion par exemple que je que j'ai
des conseillers que je que je consulte
des gens par exemple il ya eu cette
fameuse réunion aussi du conseil de
sécurité publique pour la première fois
à la juste avant que vladimir poutine ne
prononce son discours historique son
manifeste de quelle est la russie qu'il
voit avec tout avec tous et tous ces
éléments de l'appareil d'état qui ont
conseillé à vladimir poutine de
reconnaître ces régions séparatistes de
denner a les nerfs aussi ses messages
diffusés aujourd'hui par sergueï lavrov
finalement ça fait partie du dispositif
la vraie question est de savoir c'est
dans quelle mesure vladimir poutine
aujourd'hui agi seul en son âme et
conscience est ce que c'est lui seul qui
prend la décision est ce qu'il est
conseillé ce qu'il est est-ce qu'ils
consultent est ce qu'il ya des
dissensions au sein du pouvoir et de
l'appareil du kremlin ça ce serait
vraiment intéressant de savoir aussi
pour pourvoir à quoi est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre ensuite est ce qu'il y à des
dissensions un mois du terrain elena
vous était donc sur le terrain justement
lorsque le l'offensive a débuté ou étiez
vous et qu'avez vous vu alors moi au
début j'étais dans la région plus au sud
dans la région de rostov c'est le front
de marioupol il y avait quelques
mouvements de troupes un de ce côté là
encore plus depuis que vladimir poutine
a annoncé la reconnaissance des régions
dites des nerfs et les nerfs et l'entrée
des troupes russes mais finalement
c'était assez un film parce que on était
entre la russie et l'ukraine il y avait
déjà ces zones tampons entre guillemets
des républiques séparatistes de donetsk
de lougansk en conflit depuis 2014 avec
kiev et où en réalité l'armée russe
avait déjà amassé ses troupes hamas et
son artillerie hamas et son matériel
dispenser ses généraux donc ce qui est
arrivé là c'était du renfort finalement
en plus pour lancer cette grosse
offensive sur marioupol côté mer d'azov
je suis ensuite remonter plus au nord
dans la région de belgorod qui est en
face de la de la ville de kharkiv qui
est aujourd'hui attaquée parce que là il
y avait le plus gros du renforcement
militaire arrivant côté russe puisque
c'était un nouveau front qui allait
s'ouvrir sans que vladimir poutine
jusqu'à présent n'en parle pas c'est à
dire que dans la version officielle
russe c'est les républiques populaires
de donetsk de lougansk qui avance
soutenu par l'armée russe mais ce front
là c'était complètement nouveau et
effectivement je voulais voir ce qui se
passait de ce côté là oui dans la
télévision russe on ne parle pas du
combat dans le sud à odessa on n'en
parle pas de kiev de car qui sait la
profondeur sans je prends je parle quand
je parle avec des russes à moscou avec
avec des gens que des amis des gens que
je connais tout simplement qu'ils
regardent les chaînes de télévision
russe quand je leur dis kiev et bombardé
aujourd'hui par la russie ils meurent
yonnais il ne le crois pas et on ne peut
pas avoir d'informations sur les réseaux
sociaux les on peut aussi l'information
occidentaux pour le moment oui est-ce
que ça va durer on ne sait pas on parle
actuellement par exemple de fermer
wikipedia en russie mais ils ne vont pas
chercher les russes les sources
d'information alternative et ses salles
le principal problème c'est à dire qu'
il y avait au départ cette propagande
très fort depuis 2014 l'annexion de la
crimée les russes regarder la télévision
il y croyait il dit croyait à ce message
patriotique de vladimir poutine comme
quoi la russie avait le bon rôle et
qu'elle voulait tout simplement aider
les populations russophones ensuite les
gens on était fatigués par ce conflit
qui durait par cette propagande qui
perdurait et les gens vont arrêter de
finalement de regarder les chaînes de
télévision russes mais ils sont restés
sur ce message et finalement ils ne
veulent plus recevoir aucune information
de cette histoire de russie ukraine ils
vont pas chercher des sources
d'information alternative ce qui
explique aujourd'hui que il ne regarde
ni les chaînes de télévision russes pour
certains ni ni les chaînes ni les
sources d'information alternative donc
qu'ils ont des échos comme quoi willy à
une opération militaire en ukraine alors
on fait encore la chasse aux méchants
nazis ukrainien mais ils vont pas
chercher dans le détail est encore une
fois à aucun moment la télévision russe
ne dit on bombarde kiev ont bombardé les
ukrainiennes et donc les gens tout
simplement ne sont pas au courant ils
n'y croient pas